we organized this event tonight to mark
the publication in France as a concept
new book at Stacey's 1752 now some would
like to extend particularly here
that's the monthly to thank you get
started with visual concepts and shenyu
here and listen long hard work this
event is the mental processes annual
Eugene Shepherd Distinguished Lecture
meant in part to commemorate gene
Shepard who came to Columbia in 1922 two
Columbia College in 1922 and who for
many years
Jean Shepard family that's important and
I was hoping to thank the incredible
also and the Graduate School of Science
for their support and also Hammond
Center for the Humanities who were
immediately
the format's tonight which I Costello
speak first about this work about his
new work miss Stacy's then we'll have a
series of responses and questions from
our panelists and then we'll open up to
be honest for questions and discussion I
think the overwhelming response to
business here tonight speaks to the
importance of this work and I won't say
everything I could but let me just say
that it's clear that jakosky is one of
today's most important thinkers on
equality on the possibility of
egalitarian politics and also on the
rule that literature film arts play or
can play in the hospital you've ever
thought and action and I want just to
mention three recent pilots I've been
given indication of the broad range of
careful skills work the first is X basis
which was published last year with Getty
day and I've just learned that the
English translation is due out in the
spring or may next week next spring with
versa also last year
muted speech was translated as I knew
speech came out that was impressive it
was translated by James Swenson
so tonight the new speech is a major
engagement on South Park with the
Democratic impulse in literature tonight
and I also want to mention the
vocational to three other other books as
you know probably no proletarian nights
which was Jack Macias doctoral thesis on
workers on the workers archive was
recently published to be published and
by first it was the new production
volume first also published a collection
of essays stating the people essays from
the 70s and the 1980s and from the
journal and today I'm also delighted to
welcome our distinguished panelists and
the respondents who are from dinner
fields and globally engaged with and
done something with all cells were the
Mellon Dobby is assistant professor
a specialist amazing memory transfer to
the francophone literature and colonial
history she's the author most recently
of trading sizes the study of how the
Enlightenment dealt with questions of
slavery and her latest book Olivia
Maya can be found easily Talia's best
within their policy is coming up next
she's also the translator of Sarah
Kaufman books mother of words which I
mentioned in part because Sarah Huffman
flossenbürg was also one of the
cofounders of this collection that
Patricia dam is medievalist an associate
professor in the Department of English
and American literature she's the author
of promised bodies timeline vision for
reality in woman's mystical texts and
she is also the translator of angry and
the co-founder of the Graduate theory
reading James Benson is professor of
French and Dean of humanities at Rutgers
University he has published extensively
on subjects including the book Almanac
also considered as one of the first
authors of the French Revolution and his
tracks
in the world what I've been also to
speak to speakers which means to
introduce you first to the reality of
the book which I think us for most of
you all know kind of ghostly existence
you know they have interesting friends
last year who eat eat eat should come
out next year in English language so I
know but at the end of the session so
that it goes without taking on some
consistency well 20 is discussion I
shall try try to be English short
account of what I did movies boot not
what I wanted to
in a few is a step in of Germany rather
than wizard of a decision so I shall not
tell what they wanted to do but what
today I should I have done in this book
as thesis so it seems from the aesthetic
regime of art but it's a good about the
texture and bloated of what I call the
aesthetic regime of part my basic
assumption is that aesthetics the
designated discipline dedicated as
children of far of the beautiful it
designates the wedding of experience the
one within which we have been accustomed
to identify artistic practices for
personal artworks and give very specific
lot of
we've been on very reasonably to be very
do stuff for their existence primera
marks is a single estrogen they're very
basic question one that comes from my
own three occupations in discussing you
work with students I think it's a
question that is raised even more
centrally by his business to the extent
that this book elaborates and episodic
history or counter history of artistic
modernity or the aesthetic regime from
the 18th century
so I'll try to spring this very very
quickly has already been articulated as
this this undertakes across 14 different
scenes or episodes to illustrate the
emergence beginning in the late 18th
century of art and capital a
separate separate and unifying of
experience it also explodes the
paradoxical links between the emergence
of what chaplaincy are called the
aesthetic paradigm or regime and the
formation of new political communities
and new forms of subjective ation as in
all of jequan see are threatening
concepts and categories are subjected to
rigorous examination redefinition the
terms aesthetics and politics are thrown
into a new configuration and prevailing
narratives of art history littering
history realization are contested but in
the midst of these three evaluations it
seems to me that one notion the category
of the West seems to remain remarkably
stable in the in the prelude of preface
to the book you observe quickly the
sentence in translation art has existed
in the West only since the end of the
18th century
but I think some ambiguity to that to
that statement they could be taken to
mean either but it has existed in that
form elsewhere or that it was a
singularity of the West brass so there
are 14 episodes that are elaborated that
are presented unfold in France Germany
Westland Russia the United States many
involved the reinterpretation of the
heritage of ancient Greece and Rome the
esthetic regime is situated at least to
some extent loosely in relation to broad
parents of European and social political
history as well as in relation more
precisely to previous European
conceptions of art notably the
representational or magnetic paradigm so
the title or our emphasis Italian the
prophets alludes to our baths and over
my niece's which is of course subtitled
the representation we are
Western literature so I would like to
ask how you understand the status of
this category of the West which seems to
be an a priori forever what kind of
impaired in a species like all of your
work subjects the idea of medical
community's collective ''tis of
reception to careful scrutiny is the
West to be considered as a form of
collectivity as a community or to be in
business as a different kind of
framework for matrix the principle of a
specific Western regime about would seem
to carry with it the implication of
boundaries or margins and I wonder how
you imagine the relation to another side
many of us I think have been
tremendously inspired by writing the
practices by which modern liberal
democracies creates internal borders and
margins zones of discrimination and
exclusion that negates the principle of
equality I think the example of your
recent writing about how at the level of
the state and through medium war in
contemporary France the racism has been
enacted and on all the work about the
census in the wake of the massacre of
Algerians in price from 1961 so I wonder
the last point of my question how you
envisage the relation between these
critical interventions and an account of
the history of aesthetics that seems to
rest on the premise of Wester
specificity if not Western civilization
what tool to try to rethink do we think
you know what the categories that have
organized you know from terms of terms
of color terms of culture forms of
artistic practice in those countries but
basically you know I must rely on what
what I know and try and and try to
really I think the first thing you do is
the first thing is trying to want to
wiggle up to we elaborate you know the
categories for which on which should
Auriemma
you know our function our function in
the jalapeno well because maybe they
often you guys the very can turn you off
of reverence you know - of course - over
cultures and said whatever ransom and
some form of god of world of self in
dictum and surprise another
I think it's not it's not very important
you evil you are able even to think you
know constants about jubilation systems
but intermittent world no answer and
image you know in all in in Portuguese
Asia and we are period you are able
really to make comparisons that makes
sense you know and okay you know if not
I think is for me data you know what we
are going to do still you know inside
and inside tradition each other we which
are structured you as a world in which
in which only and which in fact was the
waters were literally lives lives today
so I don't think that the arrangement
that addresses the contradiction between
the in a way to some kind of question
universal as of questionable Universal
question asked about fails you know I
don't I don't think you know that you
know an attempt to do an attempt at
servant and subverting you from the
inside you want traditional of winning
it well we should oblige us you know
want you to embrace you to anyway
all forms and all forms of practice all
register of interpretation Center our
I did something which is which is
partial I know this partial you know
when really I try to analyze what what I
grew that what what I could analyze from
the party from the party to know where
were I guess it's been situated from
where I you've been well you know I know
I don't know gay men to perceive I look
at a garage we don't want what I think
it was enough it was enough for me
of course you do I think so about where
are people tell me more and we only get
one this is my point about what I don't
speak about any about about anything and
precisely you know I think if I think if
I wanted to embrace art in general it
would be precisely when you don't wear a
way of what are composing the univer of
imposing Western categories you to pour
regimes of to all versions of Patty's
life but I don't want are they going to
do question about
we do style of this book it seems very
different from the other books I'm not
it's well read and you're entirely to
work with my colleagues but this good
start season is unusual in relation to
others partly because its method is in
some ways one performative you could say
it's in it's called a poet staging there
is something about the ways in which
these scenes are staged but that makes
it almost an experiential it's less like
I would say I know you don't like the
categorize applause releases whatever
but it's less dominant like most
honorable even though he offers an
ability to witness you could say your
your philosophical ideas at work in in
the aesthetic in the medium inside it
if there's also a kind of a genealogy
and I'm curious about the ways in which
I could call it a constellation that
that might be to bend a median you know
with the a constellation or a genealogy
I wondered like you would know he's you
talk of scenes even though they you
implicitly never related to one either
especially a the kind of ultimate to us
of the book which is a redefinition of
modernity so I don't think it's an
artificial to us it's something that you
say there's an urgency to that in a way
to talk about it so there's something
about the way in which this book is
written that makes it seem and I hate to
use this term but I don't know who come
to use as an affirmative but also
slightly testimonial and I wonder what
you would say that and testimonial not
in the sense in which you criticize from
2005 when you talk about turning Arta to
into sheer effort the testimony and
and erasing the economy or erasing a
kind of a function or suppressing the
economy by yourself
but you talk about testimony for example
in one of your essays contemporary art
in the politics of aesthetics short
essay in which you talk about the four
qualities the dialectical form of the
aesthetic the senses mark today you talk
about the job the collection the
imitation of the mystery you talked
about before the mystery but it it
there's a mystery co-presence a
testimony of no presence and and I
wonder about the status of testimony and
what's being attested to hear what what
I knew about started to start of what
for me to when I had a problem you know
doing all my career you know the
parameters that's the books that people
think you know are not so ridiculous
for me after lecture and offender books
biblical things are really and what
awaited about my essentially I think
what this kind of performative this kind
of performative are right you are
perfectly right well I would say it is
my own way of doing what people will see
which familiar tell me what you know you
know she only comes from
which means Cu and for me you know for
me doing Siri you know means something
you know means precisely changing the
changing content in two years you know
they're together on something she
changes a lot of the section of
something and you can do it for
something you know when you are prefer
mechanical surgery which meant which
means for instance but whether so much
shows we nitro flavor or Italian nights
you can say to pragmatic books you know
it was only good for so many people
movement but there was Miss Universe
Monsieur it was for 400 pages you know
and I know she only about four Italia
the poor Italian not just just tension
just just Mary and when I wrote for
instance where these are women people
where what happened with what I get to
do it of God because I because it is a
routine which in a sense was with a
noodle issue while I stasis or Knights
of Labor and we was with in fact it was
written in French you know meaning
concisely by profit for me you know my
usual my no more my my but doing is
precisely you know introducing myself
you know in certain in a certain fabric
of experience
and the fryer and frying where and try
you know step by step you know from list
when we define to win a final categories
a lot of perception you know but the
vaccine vaccine person editor and this
is what I said what what I tried also to
do do do-do-do leading edge this is why
there is there is this East where this
legend you know of modern are to
Eternity it's a table was constructed by
the front of school but then Greenberg
and in where we elaborated you know we
elaborated you know biographer like
Roswell up but starts Lee you know
artists artists artists estrellas
testimony of a certain certain situation
you know of thinking about a certain
situation instead of the humanity of the
human thinking thinking animal well and
what I either I don't think I don't
think about my work is that my work is
is justice testimonies testimony on you
know what it wants to what wants to do
it well it's just an injustice just in a
sense you know what - when - just grass
- grass you know we know some some
nurses some not you know between
practice performance performance and and
and discuss you know and but narrative
by narrating vaguely also an evening
the Phenom you know something so
something like that like that you know I
hear an evening you know you must go in
1990 1912 when the other claim you know
try to try to do to make the stage the
state income and light winds and slacks
give you well in a way I think well it's
it's so easy it's a way of trying you
know to want to do to match notice the
real fabric of experience you know
within which was most memorable project
was a triangular pediments Michael to me
to make me make it make it separate
acceptable you know and in a way to what
it proved it put enough in you know it
proves nothing which is why I said of
cotton you can see these cameras to have
modernity but but but also that also in
the in a way you know is one it just it
just it just the way of when we
inventing my contract you of course we
reinventing you know what art we a man
may have made understand moment of the
creation of a certain certain sphere of
experience and in relation in innovation
innovation
so whether performative yes then the I
think it's necessary and necessarily ask
to be perform a treat for me very well
we are you know we're thinking and but
what testimonial George esta mañana I
don't I don't know exactly but you know
we put off which of course what is that
what is I of course to background what
is what is big on the noise was the
leader of our people what I said before
in the world when I was when I was
answering you know Phil's of this
question what I tried what I try to do
suggest and maybe select a form of the
similar variety is what the link another
link of so-called artistic modernity
would be second to of people of people
no longer close God to allow you to live
a new life to live able to live any kind
of to leave any kind of latitude with
which this is a reason why a lot of not
as a reason but respective reason of
course you know why she hopes you'll
notice Angeles to the last scene you
know else you know visa and you know
about you James by James a cheese noses
sharecroppers you know answer well as
important region brings you know officer
of your officer of the daughter of the
daughter of the rocker opening of the
circle which in which of course in my
view is a
what I tried you to say them out with a
little madam do very little participate
or children so I'm going to make a
couple of comments based on my
experience as a translator and trying to
construct a question out of those
comments I've translated three of Samos
Chios
the first was short voyages to the
landed people which was published first
in France in 1990 on the basis of
articles that appeared I believe
primarily in their curricula musica over
the previous decade this remains my
personal favorite among the books that
I've translated it's an intensely
beautiful book both of the level of the
sentence and at that of deep structure
it has a structural coherence I think
that is especially remarkable given that
began a separate essays the opening
chapter on Wordsworth is especially
important for me and I think
representative of why so many of us find
words were so compelling
in the way that it locates Wordsworth's
politics not at the level of what he has
to say about the French Revolution or
about the poor loss but in the most
profound identity of his poetry as it
encountered with a mundane object that
is constituted as poetic by the solitary
void that seeks them as the truth of
common experience mute scenes which
appear in translations us last year that
came out in France all the way back in
1998 is the most systematically
constructed I think of Jacques writing
on the history of aesthetics as the
history of regimes of sensible
experience as such it is in my opinion a
key text it's the it's one that I have
to work and get the rights to translate
and I was
Frank for somebody else the only
disagreement I think
Fars this sort of systematic exposition
that characterizes it speaks a month
works well I haven't got the full text I
sent it from the parts of this thesis
that I heard about this is that it
shares the narrative approach
characteristic of the short voyages but
also of the words of history or the
Knights of Labor I will always think of
it if the Knights of Labor when I speak
English they can change the title of an
approach from multiple perspectives
which rocket interviews always
associated in wealth in which the object
is grasped through the discord ensues
between these perspectives as much as
through their agreement so in opposition
to this sort of the protein which speaks
contains an account of neoclassicism or
the representative Russia Department
whose schematize ation echoes fuko's
classical history in ways that are if I
may dare say brutally illuminated I
refer to it in the classroom as often as
any exercise in literary history or
literary theory that I've ever
encountered the way of explaining some
cases
French literature works bang bang bang
if and it's an ischemic ox it's really
schema taught there's a there's a
certain flattening of you know anything
precise that one might want to say about
Christine for example that a person
commutes speech also contains a sort of
grand narrative of 19th and early 20th
century French literature running Balzac
Ravel not it may boost output vanity
that is characterized by both a constant
sense and literature as a problem to be
resolved and by the beauty of its both
readings and I often think in particular
of an extraordinary discussion of
overturned the impulse from its early
scene in Batam book in between these two
my translated a short a sentence it's
published as a block that is really on
Freud called the esthetic unconscious I
think that it has some really
interesting things to say about how
Freudian psychoanalysis relates to its
historical moment but I'm not
particularly convinced that it played an
important role in the development of
Jacques Spock what I do think it's worth
remarking upon here is that in
comparison to nude speech it was written
I did the translation before but it was
written well after mute speech
it shows a tendency for the dynamism
evidence in the discussion of the
aesthetic regime of art in the speech to
become what I would call internal
differentiation and even opposition so
that there are particular
interpretations of the aesthetic regime
that hosts themselves to one another in
a book like that also in the Beijing
these will see you look I think that
came out about the same month
so here's roughly my question um the it
has to do with the relation between the
scheme and sensation that's possible
with respect to the aesthetic regime and
the dynamism that characterizes all of
the accounts like the scheming cessation
that's possible with respect to that
receptive regime and the dynamism that
characterizes all the accounts of
aesthetic vision is this a heuristic
choice one that is we're going to see me
toss this so that it shows off this in
in greater clarity I think that's a real
possibility but I don't think it's just
half within what I've called the
dynamism of the aesthetic review do you
think that I'm right to perceive a
tendency both over the course of your
accounts and over the history that you
recount for war for internal dynamism
and difference to become differentiation
and AHS
another way to put this is to ask
whether you
told so whether you've ever counted some
scenes from the history of the aesthetic
regime or whether you in fact have
without taking history of the aesthetic
routine that itself has a Chilean form
of some sort that is to say a beginning
if it has a potential end and I
absolutely agree with you about your
past rejections of the pertinence of the
new factories but is there a way in
which the possible in which we can
understand the limits of the
aesthetically few it strikes me there
are many ways the account dynamism that
you've given is one in which infinite
recuperation and containment is possible
and that there is no way in which a
critique of the aesthetic regime can be
mounted from within Diaz medical team
that does not reproduce its most
fundamental what
yes let us see base basically you know
what I wrote I would I would have
something you know I didn't try to know
who its way obviously I could try to
make the list way out here on the estate
equation really what what were they
wanted to do what I want to do hi so led
to isolate you know another another of
seeds you know we were I believe I
couldn't make but to make what happened
what what happens you know what kind of
transformations our founder of happens
you know that man metal to make each man
make it percent making perspective or
you and it was very difficult was that a
technology because it because there are
well there are many events you know but
but I could not comment you know because
my principal where was you know from
each from each see you know I must are
uneven performance and protects to
protect accounting accounting for a
country for the performance so much so
what will it no it is perfect as
possible to get into them in interest
this issue you know of perception a
diversion perception it's at the right
scenario and well they were rather than
ever and it is it's like this not so
it's not so easy so they're they're very
guitar instance you know who are the
flag too
- I accept early on surviving on that on
drug that of course and have been a very
physical we live in a sense you know but
there was no interesting text got some
tension or Fellini oh but not not
another parent but not very interesting
and this is why France under chapter on
surah was we pressed by a chapter on the
hotel which is quite surprising in
science you know but precisely because
there is a kind of literature around
around around Road now you know which
working with which the work which was at
the same time you know and attend to
know by many critics you know I wanted
to tell what what has happened to our
today in the 1880s and 1987 until 1990
the first no text the best no texture of
this kind you know about about sir are
on Google you know and as a Harvard so
but there wasn't that they were from
stacks and and there was and there was
weakest of it which also were one of my
permanent eros
prevalent characters genuine already in
all normal in all my world you know
which protects our detection which in a
way was also kind of stink test Israel
of what could be settled for that but
this is about Jordan are kind of artist
you know we saw you the contradictions
the contradiction between naturalism and
symbolism
- moment attack I also have two
questions the mini last one so the
larger agenda the first question is to
get you talking about cinema and all
Hospital are may believe may be somewhat
obvious question it will be interesting
your answered the Stacy's has
discussions of Chaplin and bear talk but
I want to ask a question that might be
an opportunity for you to say something
about two other books you've recently
published that haven't or haven't yet
been released in English which is to say
that volume on gave us horror and this
basic are descending about the gaps of
cinema
so the question and this can be a may be
a way to say more about this books as
well but the question I was gonna frame
was to first the status of cinema in
relation to our so you've said that the
esthetic regime breaks down the
hierarchies between high and low arm
entertainment and so at the same time I
think
there's this sort of common perception
today perhaps and in the u.s. even more
the France of the category of art
functions to construct a boundary or
hierarchy between what is what counts as
art and what does not count as art and
then correspondingly the notion that
there's those with the capacity to
understand art and those who only enjoy
reality television romance novels pop
music and so on so it's an admission
that is perhaps explicitly visible in
cinema and which said that there you
know movies that everybody enjoys on a
Sunday afternoon and then there are
these other things we call art films
that depending on who you ask are either
the one true kind of cinema or from the
opposite perspective over the only a
genre film that's meant to appeal to or
flatter the cultured sensibilities of a
circle class
station so since the number of the more
contemporary films and filmmakers you
write on the avatar it pasta and so on
are considered makers of what I think
that's call arts and my question is
first more broadly to cinema oppose any
particular complications for the
aesthetic regime of art that are not
posed by say literature painting and so
on and more specifically how does one
explain the prevalence of this idea are
to let the catch the art world as well
as in our cinema as a hierarchical
concept distinct from you know the
commodifies pleasures of the Ravel and
so on if in fact the concept of art as
it emerged in the aesthetic or human
horror your arguments on dust that
distinction in the first place so how do
we that
explaining the persistence I guess of
that distinction
okay okay when the in fact we know a in
fact we think that whether it was seen
in my below old world you know always or
without an a fabulous necklace because
States and certainly certainly
with intensity Regina in the way it was
out what was expected that was expected
vices senses might I see aesthetic the
majestic logic in San Clemente super I
commented all you know English cities in
favor of you commenting on about textual
button on most eggs you're offered a
filmmaker service you do not say I think
that now yes there is there is a
possibility of free speech new thinking
in images speaking images and you know
and of course getting rid of getting rid
of for most older or who's ultimately
directories and characters and
psychologists are cosmic party not
happening but we know that at the same
time you know causes so in the 99 in the
1920s there were all those actor
instruments and also most people lose in
equitation well of course you know I
focused on the customer focused on
Charles Chaplin and
because by sight in both case you know
it's about the limits of our turn on our
calendar and on the one hand the new
church at Green was was of course what
setting leg celebrated because it was
popular entertainment of as well as I
have done at the same time and so it was
further it was precisely you know us as
kind of evidence of this new art that
was able that was able really to want to
do disrupt you see or hear like even
between I have a popular art and the
other hand and on the other hand you're
behind you without you
there was an idea of a form of art which
is no more but which is just kind of
linked early Tolu between all the
activities but imagine you can Minister
Sousa you can do look at the you can be
story so to argue out of cinema art
through art at the same time it's the
particles are other popular art which of
same time with perfectionist to party
and we all know back to what happened
what what happened of course you know is
but in a way is better
once the industrialization of art meant
meant the way the restorations or
restoration the new order of the barrel
of the barriers you know and and in a
way you know and in a way the point is
not that industries against actually the
point is that industry in persons you
know imposes you know included precise
there's a distribution between what is
artistic and what is one watching
but his entertainment and proposal
during their very survival but even we
know some of the industry kind of very
strange of a scanner very strange
industry with what else or industry
within which there was this kind of
distribution distribution you know of
you know of all you know wait you know
service also the so called data so for
directors of the camera monument almost
people who most of you know more or less
you know in fact could invest you know
there are very well they are stated that
their artistic the artistic doings or
artistic skills you know artistic skills
you know what in what was supposed to be
just in those two most cinnamon
commercial cinema and that was which is
what happened you know what happened in
Hollywood and we're very good and was
the basis to the basis for for silly
philia because because what was the
Athenian learning besides we're not very
friendly in the nineteen that in 1601 is
kind of reputation of so-called in
Oklahoma of cinema Hollywood cinema say
increases part and precisely which don't
with storming you notice this in
distinction when our unknown object but
of course we was also back to one since
that time you know industry could
perhaps make a magnetic a new statute
make a new step human and will equip who
yet we are creative we are little all
the business you know the basis mother
correct distribution you giving too
whether well what they want you either
aren't entertainment or entertainment
with some are for art which is a which
is somehow entertaining and pick up our
beautiful son together if my people I
think
you